whether you're a die-hard Game of
Thrones fan or a casual viewer it's fun
to hunt for any clues you can find from
episode to episode and the eighth and
final season is no exception
here's a look at many of the Game of
Thrones details you missed in the last
six episodes of the series one of the
most unexpected moments of the eighth
season premiere actually came in the
show's opening credits which features an
entirely new sequence with plenty of
Easter eggs the most notable change came
right at the start with reminder that
the wall that once protected the Seven
Kingdoms from the threat of the White
Walkers has been breached thanks to the
knight king's brand-new zombie dragon at
the end of last season the introduction
also added last hearth an abandoned
northern castle formerly home to the
umber family who were loyal to the
Starks right up until they were all
slaughtered by whites the map even shows
us the path that the White Walkers took
to the climactic Battle of Winterfell
and the white tiles that made up the
snowy ground flipping to black to
represent their movement after the
climactic battle in the long night
though those tiles stopped flipping
indicating that the White Walkers are
actually finished after all it's not
just the events of season 8 that have
left their mark on Westeros either
images displayed on the Bands around the
model son depict past events like the
third seasons infamous red wedding
there's also an image of three dragons
looking at a comet which represents the
red comet set to fall when dragons
appear and which made its own appearance
in season 2 of the show where the comet
means one thing boy
Tracking's finally in one of the coolest
tweaks to the opening sequence the final
episode shows the damage that's been
done to both Winterfell and King's
Landing
like the actual city it represents the
intricate clock works that race the
towers of the red keep on the map have
been broken leaving the machinery
stuttering as it tries to raise them one
last time the last time we saw
tormund Giantsbane and beric Dondarrion
at the end of season seven they were
caught up in the night Kings first
strike watching as he brought down the
wall when we finally get to check in
with them in season eight they're
tracking the destruction that the White
Walkers have left in their wake as they
traveled beyond the wall and they find a
pretty disturbing message left by the
night king the young Ned umber turned
into a white and pinned to a wall amidst
severed limbs provides the season's best
jump-scare when he really conds and has
to be set aflame it's one of the most
distressing images in the series recent
memory with umbers dead body at the
center of a spiral pattern made up of
body parts but it's not the first time
audiences have seen this pattern since
the very first episode of the show the
White Walkers have long been associated
with spirals and circles from arranging
the body parts of their victims to the
sacred place in the north and the cave
drawings that John showed Daenerys in
the seventh season perhaps most
crucially the spirals can be seen in the
scene that showed the children of the
forest creating the first walker
suggesting that these shapes have more
to do with the lore of the walkers than
viewers fully understand when audiences
first met Theon Greyjoy he was arrogant
and dismissive especially to Jon Snow
letting audiences know that perhaps
Theon needed to be taken down a peg put
away your blade take orders from your
father not you
eight seasons later and Theon's been
brought about as low as any character
possibly could he's been psychologically
broken from emotional and physical
torture leaving him a beaten man
struggling to reclaim himself and fight
for a cause he believes in after several
years of terrible behavior Theon has
fully redeemed himself by saving sonses
life and proving that he's willing to
sacrifice himself to do the right thing
now in the show's final season Theon
returned to Winterfell to fight for the
Starks even though his sister Yara
set off to retake the Iron Islands in
doing this the aunts journey has come
full circle
after starting out with the Starks
before abandoning them he has finally
come home to stand with them one last
time completing the arc of one of the
show's most troubled characters you're a
good man before she used it to put a
permanent end to the army of the Dead
arias Valyrian steel dagger already had
a pretty notable history it was first
seen in the show's second episode when
it was used in an attempt to murder bran
Stark after his fall from the tower but
it really belonged to Littlefinger
himself Lord Petyr Baelish from there it
stayed with Littlefinger until he gave
it back to bran who gave it to Arya who
naturally used it to execute
Littlefinger during his season seven
trial during the episodes big climax as
the night king makes his way towards
bran arias training helps her silently
move through the godswood until she gets
to the night king himself destroying him
with Littlefinger's dagger to save the
brother who gave it to her this knife
has had quite the journey where bran is
concerned
so it seems oddly fitting that the
weapon once intended to kill him is what
saved not just him but every human
fighting at Winterfell
Cersei spent the Battle of Winterfell
waiting out her enemies so when they
finally arrived at King's Landing to try
to force her surrender she was ready to
strike
maybe ceci will win and kill us all that
would solve all problems before the
fight began though she had one last
brutal insult to hand down to Daenerys
and her forces after her assault on
Daenerys ships near Dragonstone Cersei
captures Masson day Daenerys is
Translator confidant and best friend and
it's immediately clear that Cersei will
use her hostage however she has to in
order to achieve her bottom line
if you have any last words now is the
time in a brutal display of power
Cersei orders the beheading of poor
Musante who gives her life willingly for
her chosen Queen bravely standing in
support of the woman who freed her from
her chains
however Circe's decision to decapitate
Masson de wound up having much larger
consequences than she realized it was
one of the final things that drove
Daenerys over the edge leading directly
to the destruction of King's Landing and
to Cersei having a couple tons of bricks
dropped on her head she shouldn't have
been surprised though the last time a
blond Lannister ruler vindictively cut
off someone's head to prove a point
it was Joffrey ordering Ned Stark's
execution the act that kicked off seven
long years of warfare and prestige
television in the final days before her
death
Cersei became as sadistic as her
terrible son as one of the only
substances that can destroy a white
Walker Valyrian steel can be tough to
come by as a result only a small handful
of characters on Thrones are in
possession of weapons made out of it one
of those characters was Ned Stark
longtime warden of the north and Lord of
Winterfell and unfortunately short-lived
hand of the king to Robert Baratheon
whose family sword was a massive piece
of Valyrian steel called ice after the
honorable but naive Ned figured out that
Prince Joffrey wasn't Robert's
biological son he ended up losing his
head and ice was melted down and remade
into two new blades the first christened
widow's wail by Joffrey was barely used
before Joffrey met his own untimely end
it ended up with Jaime his uncle slash
father you said my father was my father
but my uncle is my father my father
the second sword Oathkeeper was gifted
to Brienne of Tarth though Jaime and
Brienne spent some time on opposing
sides of the conflict between the
Lannisters and the north they joined
forces again during the Battle of
Winterfell as they fought side-by-side
the two parts of Ned sword came together
once again to defend House Stark which
feels perfectly fitting as we forced
from its dark sword you use it to
Ned Stark's daughter Davos Seaworth
might seem prickly at times but his soft
side always showed around Shireen
Baratheon daughter of the late Stannis
Baratheon Shireen was afflicted by
greyscale as a baby and while healers
were able to stop the progression of the
disease
she still bore its scars on her face
making her somewhat of an outcast this
bonds her to Davos especially when he's
imprisoned by Stannis for turning
against his king while he's in captivity
Shireen teaches Davos how to read and
the two end up forming a real bond when
Davos discovers later that Shireen has
been sacrificed by Melisandre to help
Stannis's cause he's understandably
devastated with that in mind it's easy
to see why Davos and Gilly who also
learned to read thanks to Shireen were
particularly struck by a young brave
girl with a scarred face who says she
wants to fight alongside the soldiers in
Winterfell to drive the emotional point
home music associated with Shireen even
plays over the scene reminding viewers
of the young princess and her tragic
untimely end considering that he held
the position of master of whispers it's
no surprise that Lord Varys
also known as the spider traffics and
secrets it's what he's best at and what
he continued to do right up until the
very end of his life having spent time
with Daenerys his father the Mad King he
was understandably wary of the dragon
Queens quick temper and stubborn
attitude something that he brought up
with Tyrion in a conversation that led
to him being executed as a traitor each
of us has a choice to make I pray we
choose wisely Varys doesn't plot against
Daenerys for long before he's taken to
the beaches of Dragonstone and executed
by her last living dragon drogon during
the penultimate episode of the season it
shouldn't come as a surprise however
that he had a back-up plan in place to
stop Dany himself before he's hauled off
by the guards he has a cryptic
conversation with a servant girl about
the fact that Daenerys isn't eating in
hindsight it's easy to look at this as
the subtle indication of a last-ditch
effort by Varys to stop Danny before she
can launch our attack on King's Landing
it's possible that he was using one of
the show's favorite methods of
assassination trying to poison Daenerys
before she can follow in her father's
footsteps in the end her grief over
Masson day and one of her dragons kept
an heiress safe from eating anything
that Varys may have meddled with and
King's Landing
paid the price one of the most shocking
moments on the series came when Gregor
Clegane better known as the mountain
faced off in trial by combat against
Oberyn Martell despite being stabbed
repeatedly the mountain ended that fight
by knocking Oberyn down one last time
and squeezing his head until it exploded
over in sphere was poisoned however and
the mountain was given what should have
been a fatal dose of Manticore venom
that's not how it ends for you brother
you know is coming for you you've almost
known fortunately for the mountain and
unfortunately for almost everyone else
he managed to stick around
thanks to Circe's personal dr.
Frankenstein Qyburn
he didn't just become a mindless
reanimated corpse though if you need any
evidence that there was still at least a
little bit of the mountain in that
massive horrifying body it's that like
all the best fighters he still uses his
patented finishing move when he finally
showed up for the long-anticipated
showdown that fans called cleganebowl it
seemed like the mountains little brother
Sandor nicknamed the Hound was going to
meet a similar fate
no sword wound could take down the
mountain and sure enough the Hound got
locked into the Elder Clegane Skull
Crushing finale this time however that
signature move doesn't guarantee victory
The Hound overcomes his fear of fire and
sends them both tumbling over the
ramparts of the red key finally getting
an appropriate revenge for when the
mountain as a child shoved the Hound
into a fire and left him scarred for
life check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]